Mark: Alright so what we should do, is..
Mark: We should conglomerate here. We shouldn't fight them up by the entrance.
Mark: Cause those two entrances go to the same place. You know what I mean?
Mark: We should funnel them.
Wade: Let me look at the map.
Mark: Yeah, look at the map. You see, uh, we'll block off the wall immediately left to that castle
Mark: and then they'll both have to come through that same channel.
Mark: You see where I'm talking about? With the stairs? [Wade: Are we gonna start back there and work our way up?]
Mark: No, no, no. Yeah.
Mark: Wait.
Mark: We may be talking about the same thing, I dunno.
Mark: Okay, so yeah.
Mark: Just follow me. Do you like my skin first? You like it?
Mark: Hey. Hey babe. [Wade: Oh yeah!]
Wade: Pretty.
Mark: WooBAM!
Mark: Ok.
Wade: Eh!
Mark: Sooo...
Mark: So we'll... put a guardian there. We're gonna wall this off.
Mark: So right here's gonna be walls, you know what I mean?
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: We don't need to do it immediately, because these guys are gonna come this way anyway.
Mark: So we can just start putting traps in here.
Mark: So this'll be like the "Kill Room."
Wade: Should I block off, like, right here so they gotta go through it?
Mark: No, no, no.
Mark: You don't wanna block 'em off cause then they'll break the wall.
Mark: They won't break the wall if you do anything else.
Mark: So yeah.
Mark: So you wanna, like, create a maze for them to go through? [Wade: Oh, this is a wall, okay.]
Mark: Yeah this is a wall, this is a wall.
Wade: Oh, I can't put one on this wall, oh no...         [Mark's Character: Expertly placed!]
Mark: Yeah, it's fine.
Mark: This is good enough to start with because we can hit 'em with our—with our own stuff first.
Mark: And then we can hit 'em hard later.
Wade: That's true.
Mark: Mkay. Ready?
Mark: So then—then we got a lot longer to and we can retreat.
Mark: You can hit—you can pepper 'em from a distance,
and then back up towards the gate,
towards the kill zone. Y'know what I mean? [Game: They've broken through a gate!]
Mark (mockingly): They've broken through a gate!
Wade: We're gonna kill them all!
Mark: Alright, here we go. [Wade laughs maniacally]
Mark: He he HEE!
Mark: There we go, that's the stuff! [Wade: Yeah.]
Mark: That's the good stuff!
Wade: That's the good one-two punch!
(Sounds of fighting and death)
Mark: Oh yeah!
Mark: Oh yeah! That's a murder hole alright!
Wade: Oh, these are big guys!
Mark: That's okay. Ow!
Mark: Whoa, they got me good!
Mark: Alright, but that's good enough.
Mark: See, we wanna, like, try to not use all of our shit and get as many combos as possible.
Mark: Cause combos'll give us more money in the long run,
so we wanna, like, focus all of our ability right on the, uh,
right on where we need to go.
Mark: Make sense?
Wade: Yup. We got unchained already! [Mark: Oh!]
Mark: Yeah. Well that was fast! We didn't even get it last time.
Mark: What a bunch o' losers, we're not fighting there! Hahah. [Wade: Looks like we got a break.]
Mark: No, no, no, just leave it. It's--It's one of their debuffs.
Mark: So, what we're gonna do is we're gonna continue this chain...
Mark: We're just gonna--I'm just gonna place more...
Mark: Oh, I'm gonna...I'll do the ceiling things. [Wade:  Do you wanna do these back here? If you can funnel 'em--]
Wade: If you can wall 'em all the way back here I can put up a thing that does a decent amount of damage on the back wall.
Mark: Yeah? Okay. Lemme see, I-I have one, enough for one more wall
Mark: I'm debating if a long one would be better...
Mark: We'll bring them back around, we'll do one more back loop, uh, before we go there. So.
Mark: Right, come over here and pepper 'em. Yeah--don't stand on a barricade by the way, that's also not...
Mark: It'll-They'll-They'll hit the barricade if you do that.
Wade: Oh man, I like this wall trap back here.
Mark: I know, right?
Wade: Yeah, get hit by my purple gunk!
Mark: Oh, yeah.
Mark: This is the good stuff, this is how you smart it up.
Wade: Woo!
Mark: Makes sense? Alright.
Wade: That's okay! We were prepared for that this time.
Mark: (In a funny voice) Yesch we were. (Normal voice) Save your money, try not to plant anymore traps down
because I'm pretty sure we can get through this with just these.
Mark: Oh shit, they've got range-ders.
Mark: They've got ranged guys, watch out for those assholes.
Mark: Oh, shit, they damaged my barricade, I don't know when they did that.
Mark: Uhh shit.
that's- is that broken?
[Wade: Well they broke mine.]
Mark: Aoh! They broke mine. Yeah- how'd they do that?
[Wade: Oh that's not what I meant to do.]
How'd they do that..?
[Wade: I don't know.]
Mark: Okay, either way looks like we're gonna need one more.
Imma try to re-place this.
Mark: Yeah, why did they damage that? They're not supposed to do that.
That was not how that was supposed to work.
Wade: I dunno. I had to replace one the other side.
Mark: Yeah. Just try to stand in front of 'em.
And not- cuz they only hit those if
- oh hello.
Where'd the hell these guys come from?
DONT step on those barricades! Don't do it.
You keep doin' it!
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: DONT DO IT!
Mark: Okay. Good
Mark: Oh wait, you CAN destroy those slow things, oh okay.
Wade: Yeah, I thought I was damaging the one earlier
Mark: Okay.
Wade: There's more stuff coming our way, too.
Mark: Oh its just Shield Bearers. I'm not worried about that.
Don't stand on the barricade!
You keep doin' it! You keep steppin' on it!
Wade: Occasionally it's intentional just to get you to yell at me.
Mark: Well I mean they're gonna break in, we're gonna die!
Okay, now it's the other one. OKAY
Mark: So I've saved up 5,000
... To be able to do this.
Mark: Alright, I'll put my guardian down over tharrrr (there)
Wade: I think I've got like 9,000. I got alot of money
Wade: Which side do we want to go on, left or right?
Mark: Uhhh ehhh... Whatever's easiest to wall off.
Wade: Right now by default they're going left.
Mark: Okay imma put this great wall on the other one.
Mark: OHH we do not have a lot of time!
Okay! Here we go! Just start slapping things down!
Mark: Go for it! Keep slappin' Keep slappin'
Imma put wall stuff.
[Mark's character: "Oooh, this will be fun!"]
[Other character: "They've broken through a gate!"]
[Mark's character: "This will give them what they deserve!"]
Mark: Ow.
Mark: Okay here we go. This is gonna be
gonna be bad. This is gonna get bad.
a whole lot bad before it get's a whole lot good.
Wade: We could unchain
Mark: Yeah do it do it! Unchain
Mark: Don't let them through, don't let them through
Don't let 'em through, don't let 'em through. We're good (x3)
Good call, good call i forgot about the unchain
Wade: What just happened to me?
Mark: I-did you fall?
Wade: I must have, yeah.
Yeah, I guess I fell off the edge, I didn't know that was a thing.
Mark: That- That unchained that lasts a long time, we didn't need all that, they're all dead now.
Okay, it looks like they're gonna come out both of the other sides
So they're gonna come out both at once over there
So that other side should be trapped up enough that we don't really need it
Uhhhhh, we will-  ooh fire fiend warlocks yes please
Okay
I wish I could repair this
can't though...
Okay, just remember not to stand on 'em!
Wade: Yeah yeah yeah yeah
Mark: I'm gonna pepper the top one, if you wanna pepper the bottom one.
Wade: Why am I hurting right now?
Mark: Huh?
Wade: I'm dying, and I don't know why.
Mark: What?
Wade: I'm losing health.
I don't know what just happened
Mark: I don't either- ooh shit I walked in- I splinked backwards, okay.
Retreat to the trap area.
Wade: Yeah I gotta fall back
[Other character: "Our barricades are under attack!"]
Mark: Are you standing on the thing?!
Wade: No, I'm behind them
Mark: Okay, back up back up back up, all the way to uh, all the way to the guardian.
(pew pew laser space gun game noises)
Aaaand we've got thiiiis handled.
Alright, all dead, we're good! I think we won it, we won!
Wade: Yeah?
Mark: HELLL yeah!
Wade: Woo!
Mark: Oh!
Wade: unh!
Mark: Like magic baby!
Mark: You wanna go gloat in their channel?
Wade: woohoo!
Mark: I'm gonna go gloat in their channel.
Mark: GET WRECKED!!!
Bob: -hit the button and you progressed, did you disconnect both of us?
Bob: I don't understand this game.
Mark: Hehehe dude, I played the crap out of this.
Jack: I lagged out in the middle of it, my character, like everything froze.
Mark: Oh Okay alright
Mark: I'm not- that wasn't a (sarcastic) Ooh Oookay alright, it was a (serious) oh okay gotcha.
Bob: I took the least amount of damages. Yeah!
Mark: Good for you man, congratulations.
Wade: I never remember to summon any of the extra monsters to go after you guys.
Mark: You don't? God damn it *laughing*
Wade: I always forget that that's a thing
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: I summoned them but they did no damage to any of you guys.
Mark: No, they did it was a - it was a bit of a problem
Wade: we-we had some issues i died...
Bob: Jack's did but mine did not.
Mark: Yeah- who was placing down all the slows?
Bob & Jack: Me.
Mark: Fuckin' douche.
Bob & Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Both of you! We had like 17 slows, all at once.
*everyone laughing*
Wade: We didn't know we could destroy them so we just like left them there for a good portion of the game
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: We were having a chill time just like talking, and comparing boob sizes and stuff.
Mark: Hey, my-my, c'mon guys my boobs are obviously the best boobs.
Bob: Uh you don't even have boobs.
Bob: Uh That's true, yeah.
Mark: What are you talking about? I got some sweet tits!
*cough*
Bob: Not really.
Jack: You got some sweet baps bro?
Mark: I got some luscious baps
Bob: You're a- you're a flat-chested bitch.
Jack: Oh! OH!!
Mark: Okay (x a lot)
Wade: That burned me, it was such a burn!
Mark: *still saying okay*
Jack: It's best to ostracize yourself to "general" chat for that one.
Mark: *sigh*
Bob: Oh-h, shit.
Mark: Okay
Bob: Me or him?
Mark: Okay (imagine that)
Bob: You gonna say something other than "okay"?
Mark: Just, okay, all right?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Just okay!
Bob: Good
Mark: Yeah!
Jack: Pussy assed bitch!
Bob: Good!
Mark: Jesus!
Mark: Okay?!
Jack: Bitches!
Bob: GOOD!
Jack: Sons of fucking bitches don't- who even gives a shit?!
Wade: Sabotage.. uh oh.
Jack: Game's ready.
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: "Sabotage."
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: So they're coming through this way first, which way do we wanna guide them?
Mark: That is the question.
Wade: There are a lot of walls to move them out of here even if we tried!
Mark: Yeah
Mark: Well, I think the obvious choice is to...
*horse lips*
the obvious choice is to run them in a way that they would match up with the other hallway
so-
Wade: Yeah that's walling off right here, isn't it? I think.
Mark: Yeah, wall off this one, we don't touch that, and then eventually... walk over here with me.
We'll wall off, for the other guys,
we will wall off...
this- this area here, this area here, so that they have to go this way to join up with the other path, you know what I mean?
Wade: Okay, yeah
Mark: That makes the most sense to me.
Mark: Uhh, uhh
Wade: Yeah, I agree. That gives us a long way to work here.
Mark: Yeah, so in the meantime just fuckin', spam up, 'cuz this is a big area.
Douche! did you even ready? Are you the one holding it up?
Wade: Yep.
Mark: Do~uche!
Here they come.
Ooh, it's fasties.
(blam, blam, blam)
Mark: Oh, they are, they are lit. They're lit, bruh.
Wade: Yeah
Mark: They're lit fam.
(battle noises)
Mark: So far so good.
Uh, oh, we been slowed.
Alright, just watch these Kobolds, 'cause they're gonna, if the guardian doesn't stop them they're gonna be a bit of a pain in the ass.
Wade: They're coming through the other side now.
Mark: Okay, so I'm gonna place down my long wall but I don't think it's gonna be enough.
So you're gonna need to- if you have the small one...
Wade: Where can I wall here?
Mark: It's just right here. Down here, get down here.
We're just gonna block off here, and then they'll have to go through this and back to connect to the long hall.
So, we'll fight them-
Wade: I can block off here too, make them go back around through this other guardian, but-
Mark: I wouldn't bother, some of them will, anyway. Uhh, I'd rather not waste money on the walls.
Money, money, money.  $)
That $weet combo money- uh oh
Wait, oh, F—, they came the other way, they must have summoned something.
Shit, they did. Ah, fuck.
Wade: Oh God (x3)
Mark: We got a LOT of- how did they get so many boss minions?
Wade: I don't know.
Mark: Either way, they're dying, but out guardian might not be able to stop this.
We're in a bit of a spot of bother here.
How did they get this many boss minions??
Fuuck
[Character: "The rift has been compromised!"]
Wade: Oh God.
Mark: Yeah, that- that sucked I don't know, have you been sending your dudes over to their team?
Wade: I sent some—, I sent something, yeah.
Mark: Yeah, send them every time, yeah, but, okay. That's fine. They took more damage than we did.
Alright, this is good, this is good. Okay, this is fine.
Wade: Did they break our thing over here?
Mark: No, they did not.
Alright, so they're gonna come through both now, now we gotta really fill this place out with some traps.
Okay, here they- here come a buttload of 'em.
Ooh...
Metric buttload incoming
Okay, focus on the Kobolds.
[Character: "We are close to victory!"]
Oh, we did it! Yaay!
Good, 'cause we were about to lose.
Wade: Yeah, we were really close to losing.
Mark: How in the hell, man?
Wade: I don't know, that was insane.
Mark: It's too big, I think that's meant for three people, 'cause there's no way that two could have done that well.
Wade: That was nuts. Even with the good strat.
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: We were ab—It's a good thing you lost, because we were just about to.
Jack: Yeah, we got fuckin' rolled.
Mark: Oh God yeah.
Jack: This map was weird.
Mark: Yeah we were on the way.
Bob: That map was fucking impossible!
Wade: -bosses round 2?
Mark: Yeah, how did you guys- you- so many bosses, you guys sent out like everything!
Jack: I don't know, I got fire elementals as a consumable.
Bob: Jeez.
Mark: Yeah, that, that's a REALLY tough one to beat.
Wade: Yeah.
Jack: *chuckles*
Jack: We, we-
Wade: You just wrecked our guardian.
Jack: We chose wrong chokepoints, and then we left ourselves a back door, that was a bad idea *laughs*
Mark: Yeah
Bob: Yeah, that was awful.
Wade: I don't know, we didn't choose bad chokepoints, but somehow-
Mark: It didn't matter anyway, there were so many of them.  Yay.
Wade: Yay.
*chuckling*
Mark: Buh-byee!
I don't know, I was just, like, putting that in there, just in case.
Jack: Outro?
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: See ya, guys!
Jack: IN THE NEXT VIDEO!!!
Mark: *laughs*